like it or not lockdown has become a way
of life and we're all still trying to
find
ways to adjust people should be staying
at home
unless they have a valid reason to leave
the idea though of going off on a
holiday for some
sun sea and sand has seemed pretty
unlikely
that is until the vaccines came along
today marks a new chapter in our fight
against this virus
the rollout of several different kobit
19 vaccines
really did raise our hopes that life
will soon start to return to normal
but looking ahead will we be able to
have our summer holidays
last year more than 9.5 million people
were practically left with no choice but
to cancel their holidays because of
covid19
it is illegal to leave home
to travel abroad for leisure purposes
the lockdown introduced at the start of
this year included some strict rules
around travel
you must stay at home unless you're
legally permitted to go abroad
for medical reasons work that can't be
done at home
or educational reasons i think it's far
too early
uh you know there's still 37 000 people
in hospital with kovic at the moment
it's far too early for us to begin to
speculate about the sun
the government is trying to stop
coronavirus variants from reaching this
country
which means tougher restrictions on
travel people coming back to britain
from countries with coveted 19 variants
like south africa
portugal and south america now have a
mandatory hotel quarantine
it is clear that there are still too
many people coming in
and out of our country each day anyone
coming back from these so-called redless
countries
will have to quarantine for 10 days in
government assigned accommodation
at their own expense so new zealand's
had no community transmission for months
and months
and they catch it at the border by
asking people to isolate for two weeks
not just asking them putting them in a
hotel and making sure they stay there
and also looking after them if they then
get sick
in western australia where i am there's
not really any hotel quarantine
facilities
that have opening windows so there's no
access to fresh air for two weeks which
i'm sure medical professionals would
agree
that is very important and all travelers
from any country must self-isolate for
10 days
even if they have a recent negative test
result
because a new variant anywhere
poses a potential threat everywhere you
also have to give your contact details
and address so authorities can make sure
you're sticking to the rules
we know that people are gonna want to
fly again
you know the most important thing is
that the governments and countries get
control of these infections and
suppresses them down
so travel can go back to some type of
normality that is the key things
there's also this to think about will
other countries even allow
tourists from britain to visit the new
variant already discovered
in britain in december last year meant
several countries banned flights from
the uk well countries across the world
imposing restrictions on people
traveling to and from the uk because of
their concerns about this new emerging
strain of coronavirus if you are able to
travel make sure your hotel has free
cancellation
and avoid deposits where you can or
better yet
book a package holiday that is atoll
protected to make sure you get a refund
it's not looking too good at the moment
so it might be worth
just for the time being pinning your
hopes on a staycation
you